[Music]
what's up guys on someone and I'm Jake
Gyllenhaal I'm we're gonna play first
impressions oh yeah
which is a game where you have to do
impressions and I suck at them so joke's
on me let's see oh this is terrible give
it well like oh yeah oh yeah no clearly
forget we're different generations yeah
like oh yeah nothing I can't do it I
don't know all right
like it's like a goody baby yeah so I
say hello to my little friends Oh
Scarface god it's for my job yes
Scarface guy that's good perfect
yes I don't know how to do this one okay
no I don't know I don't know I just know
a thing okay
it's not it is a thing but it's not a
thing try your best
we're in London we're going down the
street to a funky B oh yeah and I'm
gonna get a haircut two second
freestylers you can do whatever you want
oh he's like I was like trying to be
I'm in London I was like little hands
really give the t-rex away because it's
like the universe was like oh come on ha
ha I'm an animal I don't know like what
makes that noise an octopus no dolphins
oh oh you know what a good impression
else
I used to freaked my mom out when I was
young like Yuri okay Chewbacca yeah I
was good at or a trip to my dentist
hey I'm spider-man is that supposed to
be funny I am I won't I'm spider-man
okay I got one hallo check this one out
whoa whoa whoa spider-man
whoo do that do the time no loss just
keep doing it cuz I don't want to answer
because I wanted to keep doing this yeah
cuz that's what they do do they do the
chicken Oh ostrich no that was actually
a better bird it's a bird obviously okay
well there's little wings cuz you mean
your wings are those little wings small
bird crow we're two lads and we're just
in London stop yeah
children nice to meet you that's not
mrs. Doubtfire I'm brilliant
okay back projection baa baa baa black
sheep Shaun the Sheep a she-goat oh yeah
what's this dude press to operate
the definition of thumb press the big
red button again
[Music]